[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
we know that Fox News is about to
[__] Liars you know it feels like
this isn't news
[Music]
neither is Fox News they're not news
either
oh [__] so apparently Rupert Murdoch was
coordinating with Jared Kushner and he
didn't believe a goddamn thing Trump was
saying which who believes anything that
[__] fat slob says
is there a person out there that
actually believes his nonsense and his
[__] I mean there might be a few
in in all actuality Rupert Murdoch is
one of the richest [__] in the
world
even with this Dominion lawsuit because
they're likely to win here and it's
probably going to be settled at a court
I'm surprised Rupert Murdoch has taken
it to this extent though uh inside of
Discovery
they're always they're always listen if
they're accusing if they're accusing the
left the leftist lunatic Marxist whoa
crowd of doing something they're doing
that exact thing
it's always projection
oh jiben and the Democrats are
coordinating with the media
to to steal elections and then lie about
it get the [__] out of here with this
[__]
no one on the liberal left [__] likes
the mainstream media because they're not
liberal they're not I I'm I'm liberal
media I'm liberal Independent Media that
is what I am you [__] shitty morons
come after me [__]
come after me
they're MSNBC CNN the New York Times the
New York Post all that all that [__]
that is not liberal media
those are journalists I'm media
I get to say whatever the [__] I want
whenever the [__] I want and how I want
that's right and I will do it too and
I'll do it with a liberal bias because
that's who I am
and that's what I want so piss
piss off Lou
that's exactly what this show is
designed to do
but I don't carry water for the Biden
Administration
I've never been invited to the White
House have you hi Evan and if I was if I
was can you imagine
oh I mean you know I'm not saying they
know who I am but I'm saying they
probably know if there's a clown out
there saying crazy [__]
but if I was invited can you imagine
what a mistake that would be to invite
me to the White House oh my God that
would be a horrible mistake on their
part not I mean I I wouldn't go
I wouldn't go if I was invited and I
would tell you I promise if they invite
me I will turn them down I promise I
will turn them down and I will tell you
I will show you on social media
there's no way no way held shape and
form is my ass supposed to be at the
White House no matter the administration
no matter the [__] president
I'm I'm supposed to hold these
[__] accountable
and frankly it's very easy to hold the
Biden Administration accountable they're
doing exactly what they should be doing
which is governing I don't know but
we're going to watch a a clip of Pete
Buddha judge doing exactly what the
American people want in Kansas
that's right they're accusing Joe Biden
and not wanting to go to Ohio because
it's a red State you are a bunch of dumb
[__]
have you even have you even glanced at
the infrastructure Bill have you even
[__] glanced at it to see what
[__] states that it benefits the most
how and how in the [__] are we supposed
to have a national divorce when red
States take way more [__] tax dollars
than they'll ever [__] pay and that's
fine by me that should be fine by every
American
but we have to have the messaging in the
narrative behind it so these [__]
deluded Little Country folk and I'm not
I'm not knocking on them that they're
country folk real people are good people
they really are they're just not
attached to reality in this timeline
they're just not
I'm gonna show you another example
Donald Trump Donald Trump [__] on
Farmers yesterday totally [__] on
Farmers basically told them if he
becomes president they will not be able
to trade with [__] China
do you have any idea do you have any
idea the percentage of our of our farm
Goods that are traded to China
do you remember what happened when
Donald Trump killed Farmers trade with
China he had to give them the biggest
socialist payment we have ever given any
group of people in this country up to
that point in history
that's what this show is about the show
is about plucking heads out of asses
that's what it's about
to get people to understand that you're
being lied to
it's gonna take a long time though like
you can't expect these [__] eaters and
there's a lot of them that come here you
you see the trolls every [__] day the
Trump sense the Elon sense you see them
here every [__] day
and I welcome them
we have we have to get them to listen to
this stuff
their best interest is liberal democracy
not autocracy
or authoritarianism they will be crushed
by it
these weak feeble simple-minded
people
who only want a a a a narrative that
fits their bias
will be crushed by authoritarianism
absolutely crushed by it they won't have
the strength
that it takes to defeat it when it comes
after them they just won't
they don't have the fortitude to
understand that they're voting for their
factories to leave their towns when they
vote Republican
they don't understand that their rights
are at risk that they sow their freedom
that they care about so much is at risk
because they're voting Republican their
towns are being filled with toxic sludge
because they vote for Republican
it's gonna take a long time to reach
them it really is oh my God it's gonna
be a long hard battle
but but the the the elitist liberals on
the left are not going to attract these
people they're not with your [__]
data and your [__] polls and your and
your stupid [__] arguments that take
six hours to explain one point
it's not hard for people to understand
that they don't want to go broke because
of a medical bill it's not hard to
understand that parents want their kids
to start early so they don't have to pay
for as much daycare
it's not hard to understand that people
want higher education without the huge
[__] cost that puts them out of the
realm of succeeding in this country
people want manufacturing back here
people want a decent [__] wage and
the security of a job it's not
complicated
you don't have to [__] tell them
facts and data and polls and blah but
blab a [__] blah to get that point
across
and that's why I do this show every
single day
in the format that I do it in everyone
loves the format
I don't know if you guys know this but
we have um
we're having about in the last month
we've had about the same amount of
people viewing the show so we haven't
grown the audience which seems like a
disappointment
you know I'm being transparent with you
we get thousands of people that watch
this show every day across platforms
whether it's Twitter Facebook uh YouTube
twitch
and we're growing the audience very
gradually and over the last month it's
it's it's been level
but you know one thing that's that's
changed drastically that I noticed
yesterday when I looked at the numbers
you guys are watching this entire
[__] show the whole thing front to
back from the time that the stupid
elevator music goes on until the headass
is speaking on the phone
you guys are our view time is up
Big Time huge thousands of hours every
single month than the last month
that means what I'm doing is working
and that's the key to this whole
democracy thing and it's the key to
battle Fox News and their nonsense
they're [__] lies and their mind
[__] of their [__] viewers
that's how we undo it you share this
show I'm telling you I know I seem like
I'm patting myself on the back and I'm
I'm using crazy [__] talk that I
might be the antifa Rush Limbaugh the
left but let me tell you something it
[__] worked
Rush Limbaugh worked it worked in their
favor we can make it work in hours
I'm telling you and I'm being
transparent about it they're not gonna
they're they're not gonna tell their
viewers what they're doing
I'll tell you what I'm doing
I'll be transparent man I don't give a
[__]
it's exactly what I'm doing 100 I'm here
to talk every day
to get people to slap people in the face
and again I like the phrase to pluck
their heads out of their ass
and understand that they are being lied
to
liberalism is not weak it is strength
Fox News
wokism isn't what you think it is
you nincompoop Nazis I know you're using
Code words when you say woke Ron
desantos who is not getting in the race
I'm going to show you a [__] clip
from Fox News
of a morning coverage at a restaurant
and and I'm I'm telling you it's proof
it's only proof of what I'm saying is
true
you're not you're not going to get
around this Donald Trump is going to be
their nominee rather Fox News wants it
or not rather Republican party or Paul
Ryan wants it or not they know that
motherfucker's gonna be their nominee
they know it they know it
I know it getting used to it it's time
to start the fight
stop trying to [__] oh well no I mean
Joe Batten he's old well what about
would that Ron DeSantis
he's not gonna even if he earners the
race he will get crushed
I'm telling you
doubt me on this just [__] doubt me
you come here every day and you listen
to me two hours a day five days of
[__] week some of your members on
patreon and listen to me on Sundays
thank you by the way
to all the patreon members out there and
the [__] fam on patreon
it's uh it's growing over there rapidly
we're at like 122 this morning
we got to 100 fast it was quick fast in
a hurry and my next goal is 150. so if
you're out there and you're listening
and you want you want more of this rant
on the weekends you want early access to
social media we're going to do a patreon
party here soon
if you want access to that stuff just go
check out the patreon patreon.com the
Tony Michaels
or go to the Tony michaels.com you can
click the the link there
become a member or just check it out
just see what's uh what's going on over
there
anyways anywho anywho back to back to
fake news
Rupert Murdoch
so it was then that was colluding with
the administration with the government
of course we knew Fox News was State
News and we know now that the reason why
they were pushing the big lies because
of um the greed
because they they knew they knew these
chuckleheads were going to believe this
nonsense
that they're viewers they're viewers
they Fox News knows their viewers
are really ignorant they know it they're
very hyper aware that that their [__]
viewers don't know [__] about [__]
hyper aware about it
and they understood that their [__]
viewership was gonna buy the big lie
Hook Line Sinker and if they didn't grab
Their audience with that piece of bait
of the big lie then Ohan and Newsmax was
gonna gobble up that [__] viewership
they understood that Rupert Murdoch
doesn't have all the money in the world
because he doesn't understand media
unfortunately Rupert Murdock understands
media really well the same way exactly
the same way that Rush Limbaugh
understood how to talk really well
and how to communicate really [__]
well unfortunately these vile pieces of
[__] have these talents and they're
using them not for good
not for legacy but for their own [__]
greed
and their own [__] fascism
it's what's happening you you just look
at one clip of Tucker Carlson and you
can pull any clip at random and you know
what's going on there
they know their [__] audience is
ignorant
they know it
so they feed them ignorant porridge
it's what they do
I mean Jesus Christ yesterday yesterday
the department of energy comes out and
it's like you know what
it is a very low possibility very low
possibility that the virus was released
from uh Wuhan Wuhan lob lab onto the
world it's very very unlikely and
they're like oh master
Biden is still on got lockdowns and all
kinds of crazy ass lies
that don't exist let me tell you
something Fox News viewers where I'm at
in Trump country
these [__] ignorant [__] sheep
that around here
in in Central Missouri
that watch Fox News these dumb
[__] haven't had a lockdown or
a mask requirement
since [__] June of 2020
what the [__] are they talking about
it doesn't matter it's all imaginary
it's all fake it's all fraud it's all a
good story to make them feel good about
their [__] bigotry oh Tony what does
this have to do with racism what doesn't
have to do with racism with these
[__]
Jesus Christ that's the only thing they
can focus on is what Eminem has what
genitalia and what color is it
you think that's a coincidence hell to
the [__] no that's not a coincidence
that's a feature not a glitch
they're absolutely out of their [__]
minds and the reason why is because
they've convinced them of all kinds of
crazy [__]
because we weren't doing our job folks
liberals Democrats the left Democratic
Socialist moderate whatever the [__] you
want to call them the pro-democracy
Coalition dropped the ball for 30
[__] years in this country wasn't
someone pounding the drum every
[__] day holding these stupid
bastards accountable to their [__]
lies and exposing them to average normal
everyday [__] people
who are more worried about who's going
to throw the football on Sunday than
politics in general but it matters and
that's why we have to be there yelling
and [__] screaming
and I'm just one microphone I'm just one
but I can reach a lot of you and a lot
of you are a lot of microphones
that's that's the idea
that's what they did they've done that
over the last 40 years
25 years almost 30 with Fox News
what do you think Roger Ailes plan was
it worked
it worked folks
and it can work with the truth the same
then it works with lies it works
so whenever you see some commentator or
some pundit out there I don't give a
[__] who it is if they're speaking
against the Democratic institutions that
we have turn them off
if they start giving you [__] data
about polls and this and that and how
much data here and in 1983 turn them the
[__] off
the reason why is because that narrative
is [__] [__] and garbage
it's not going to advance our narrative
and our [__] democracy it won't
oh but Tony we need we need facts based
analysis
you again are not paying attention if
you think that's how it works you are
not paying attention this is not [__]
NPR
this is not a half a percent of the
country wanting to sit
and thumb through
Stacks and stacks and stacks of data
to know what they know is [__] we
know Fox News is a bunch of [__]
lines scumbags
do you really do you think you need to
thumb through
hours and decades worth of evidence that
Fox News is a bunch of lion scumbags
just come here I'll show it to you in
the two hours
and [__] I'll play two clips
and you'll know that they're lying
[__] scumbags
you want to know that that tyt is
anti-democratic yeah that guy said it
they're on our side no they're not no
they're not
get over it
just because they're liberal doesn't
mean they're on our side
you either are fighting for democracy or
you're hurting it one or the other
you choose
when you're talking about how you
shouldn't vote because there's no
candidate worth it oh and that's all the
[__] media is talking about well
who's gonna run against Joe Batten is
Joe Batten too old well let's bring up a
poll and see what's what 1500 American
people who know [__] about [__] what
they say about Joe Biden's age and how
they don't like it who gives a [__] that
is not how politics works
that's not how it works it doesn't
matter who [__] hates Joe Biden who
doesn't want him to run because he's old
that doesn't matter
and if you're too ignorant to understand
that you're going to miss it every
[__] time
and Fox News will continue
to lay toxic waste on our country
without the protection of the truth
because you're not going to shut them
the [__] up folks this and that's the
other that's the other crazy [__]
thing that I can I can't wrap my head
around when people are like oh they need
to take them off the air they need to
shut them down why just make a better
[__] argument
if our arguments are better and no one's
watching that garbage they'll shut down
themselves or they'll change what sells
that's what we're doing here folks we're
changing what sells
that's that's the work we're doing every
[__] day is changing what sells
I mean I think I think one good result
that could come
from this Dominion lawsuit
is the agreement that news has taken off
their moniker
you can't stop them from talking you
can't stop them from broadcasting
even if Rupert Murdoch is is
[__] scent packing into the Poor
House someone's gonna out someone else
is gonna step in they're gonna step in
it's gonna happen
It's Entertainment and it's valuable
meaning they make a lot of [__] money
off of it
a lot of [__] money and greed is a
[__]
we just have to turn this [__] on their
head
so if you hate Fox News I mean you
[__] hate it and you think and you
think
that Fox News
is just the toxic sludge of our society
then what you need to do
is support
Independent Media
that is liberal
that fights that nonsense not the
mainstream media
not journalist
liberal media like right here the Tony
Michaels podcast yes I am asking you to
support me not not I mean if you've got
if you want to give monetary support on
on the patreon page fantastic we're
welcome to come on over it's it's it's
getting hot over there
more and more people are joining more
and more people are commenting we're
talking over there come join
we're having fun on on Sundays with the
Sunday rant
come join that go to the merch store if
you if you want to do monetarily
I'm talking about sharing this I'm
talking about talking about it I'm
talking about liking retweeting on if
you're on Facebook share it to someone
else share it on your timeline send it
to people and DMs
spam the [__] out of everyone you know I
know that sounds crazy but
do you know how their message works
that's why it feels like it's such a
battle to get rid of this right-wing
thinking
but we can make it
we can make it together
we can kick their [__] ass
I promise you then because I'm not gonna
stop
as as long as long as I can do this
financially as long as I can do this I
will do it I promise you that until the
bitter [__] end
but you have to do your part
which is not just support the show
but go out there
and engage in your democracy that is how
we shut down the lines of Fox News that
is the exposure that we need of Fox News
is expose people to a real and raw
truthful message
give them a message that they can get
behind
give it to them
you can kick some ass
we'll kick some ass some fascist real
America First Nazi party ass everyone
Texas Paul is going to be joining us
today you know it's Tuesday it's Texas
Paul Tuesday everyone's excited about
Texas Paul being here on Tuesday
and we're gonna have Gabe Sanchez I
think uh let's see
um
I was having trouble with something
we're good now we're good now we're
gonna go to a break when we come back
we're gonna have Texas Paul we're gonna
go through the [__] in this Roundup I
got a ton of Clips I want to show you
there is a so many clips that I want to
show you
so many that we have to get through so
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
years Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Tuesday
what the [__] that means as long as I
send in the link uh Texas calls easier
he's here don't worry he's here I may or
may have not forgot to um send in Texas
Paul the link uh to the Show oops uh you
forget something I forget you forget I
forgot what about you text well do you
ever forget anything every once in a
while that happens I'm glad you message
me more and more now that I get older
yeah well you're stroking your white
beard is that um
you know I thought about dying it once
but I just I just can't do it I know it
makes me look 10 years older than I am
but I don't even care I like it oh I see
well the audience can't see it on the
camera normally but I do have a lot of
gray hair going on and I'm sure
eventually which as long as we still
have to go after Marjorie Taylor green
um I'll be grayer and grayer and grayer
as it goes along for sure but shout I
got a shitload of video today holy [__]
busy Newsday oh my God it's gonna be a
hell of a week I said yesterday is going
to be a whole week yesterday was kind of
quiet but but it I I knew it was going
to pick up
um one of these things is the um the the
Rupert Murdoch uh exposed lives which we
all knew this was happening
this is not [__] this is this is not
hard to understand uh why when they say
oh on Fox news they say oh the liberal
media is conspiring with the White House
and they they colluded to overturn an
election on this [__] [__]
when we know that's what they were doing
right I mean it it's at projection every
[__] time you can count on it right
or am I wrong yeah no you're absolutely
right we I mean we had a we knew what
was going on behind scene behind the
scenes but man isn't it great just to
see it laid out and discovered you know
in in as part of Court records so that
the the uh righty
uh wimps just can't I mean they can't
deny it they can't be it's oh you're
just making [__] up oh no no this is
really what he said under are they but
are they actually going to believe this
stuff because Fox News isn't going to
report this [__] Fox News is going to be
like oh our owner the owner of our
network is a scumbag liar and he made us
lie and we continued to lie I mean
they're not gonna say that [__] no it's
gonna have to be from the from our
audiences they you know we've already
seen it already seen it this morning and
guys like well he made it up and it's
like you just made that [__] up your
butt hurt you're this that and the other
it's like no actually it's a matter of
court record there you go you know so
that's what it's going to take well I
mean here is um here's Jesse Waters
yesterday now yesterday the department
of energy released a report and said it
has low confidence like there it is very
it is very unlikely there is a low
possibility of the virus being released
from a Wuhan lab is what the report says
you don't believe me go [__] read it
you know whatever you want to do go read
it but the actual quote is low
confidence but this is Jesse Waters
yesterday not just pushing the Wuhan lab
[__] but pushing every other [__]
life listen to this stuff and listen to
the logic here it's Insanity the logic
here
you know the real reason this lab leak
theory is coming out of the Biden
Administration now
because China is considering selling
weapons to Russia for the war in Ukraine
so this is the U.S government saying oh
yeah
if you're going to try that Beijing
we're pinning the lab leak on you
Shanna doesn't want that
we'll probably never know the whole
truth about anything but we do know the
government lies about everything so
Texas poem the government lies about
everything then why are they not lying
about this he's like oh I trust this
this the government to say this but
everything else that doesn't fit my
narrative I don't trust that what a
[__] chucklehead
yeah it's it's crap coming out of boxing
and I've got to be honest with you Tony
I I have said from the beginning the
most plausible explanation for how this
happened was yeah they had a lab they
had a leak in the lab they had a couple
lab employees go to the hospital
and you know I I absolutely believe that
I believe that they got themselves
infected went to the hospital and and
there you go right not this intentional
[__] and not not right the
government's lying to you but that's
what the report says is there's a very
low likelihood that that is the way that
it actually got transmitted because they
don't have evidence it's funny a thing
called evidence and I get I get that
China is hiding the evidence like that's
the reason why our government is
actually frustrated about covet and has
been since the beginning is because they
have not been given the evidence that
they need to figure out what actually
happened right I mean that's really
that's really the story here is that the
department of energy did a study or did
did the research and said look we have
low confidence because of the lack of
evidence that China is giving us that
this left the lab it's likely it may be
possible it looks like it could be but
we don't have the evidence to be
confident about it and you never will
support this right well right because
China's not going to give this over and
then the actual conspiracy theory that
this has something to do with [__]
Russia is mind-boggling I mean just they
they they will do anything do genuinely
like to [__] Putin I don't know what
Putin has on Rupert Murdoch because I
used to think that that um Putin owned
Tucker Carlson some of these other hosts
but after the Rupert Murdoch uh exposure
of what he really knew about this [__]
and how deep he was in in the actual
idea that this is all lie Jared Kushner
was trying to get him to push it I mean
they were colluding to to [__] push
this big line promote it is that I I
actually believe Putin has something on
Murdoch is what I actually believe I
mean at this point I mean am I even my
crazy to think that no you're not crazy
to think it I I I think let even less of
Rupert Murdoch I don't think he's being
blackmailed I just think he's
sympathetic to Putin's views I mean he's
he's an [__] he's always been an
[__] he claims you know like in his
testimony well it's not red or blue it's
green it's it's all about making money
but there's been so much [__] that has
happened at Fox that that you know they
they could have a crossover audience if
they weren't so [__] partisans you
know I mean if they weren't so insane
it's he tries to hide behind that oh I'm
just making money selling the Rubes but
no I I really believe he's all in the
tank for Putin I mean I I I don't think
it's you know he got caught in an
embarrassing
videotape or [__] that you know
compromat this [__] Russia likes to do I
I really believe like Elon Musk
um that's just who he is man that's who
he that's who he is we're just fine
tyrion's gonna protect authoritarians
right exactly what well let's finish the
rest of this clip because you know it is
Jesse Waters so I want to give stupidity
it's due here
and you start to realize conspiracy
theories are anything that threatens
corporate profits
it really and decoding Fox News had this
clip up if you're not following decoding
Fox News you're missing out
um here was her take on it uh she says
Jesse water makes a lot of assumptions
with scant evidence because there is no
evidence that's what the department of
energy was trying to say is look we
can't figure this out because we don't
have the evidence
um the government always lies you the
energy Department says the virus might
have come from a lag leak and that that
lie that the government's telling you
because they always lie to you is proof
that the lab leak happened it's really
stupid [__] logic that they're using
yeah but like you said it's Rubes that
are that are that are that are buying
this stuff right that's who's buying and
and really they're ignorant of the truth
there's nothing wrong with listening to
the Department of energy and their take
on it I mean there's nothing wrong with
that the government has come out and
said that this although we don't think
it's a high likelihood is a possibility
that it happened this way okay great but
to think that there's some like giant
conspiracy to Blackmail China because
believe me we have way more powerful uh
ways to Blackmail China than than oh
we're gonna we're gonna turn over some
evidence that says that we believe
you're responsible for this because like
you said the evidence the physical
evidence isn't there China's never going
to give it up because if they do
they become financially liable for
everything that happened after
right I mean
no no well I was going to say back to
the Russia part and China the one thing
that the government is doing right now
currently
um and today I think is I think today is
the deadline on this me and you both are
on Tick Tock um we kind of got our start
on Tick Tock so the game Sanchez got
kind of a a following on Tick Tock and
um I think the government's actually
using Tick Tock as their carrot for the
Russia thing and here's what I mean by
that
um I don't think tick tock's gonna go
anywhere I don't think they're going to
ban it nationally I think what they want
is reassurance that Tick Tock USA
because a lot of people don't understand
this either is that there's a United
States division of tick tock and then
there's the actual Tick Tock because
there are two different types of social
media platforms there in here
um that that they want reassurance the
two Tick Tock USA that the data that's
being collected will stay here with Tick
Tock USA I think it's what they want
reassurance for and they're not getting
that reassurance that's why the
government is very very very strong in
saying we're going to ban this [__]
amp
um because Tick Tock makes a shitload of
money off this app I mean a [__]
shitload of money off Tick Tock the
creators don't make a goddamn thing but
the app makes a ton of [__] money I
mean am I am I wrong in saying that this
this idea that the lab leak is being
used it's more likely the the government
is actually using this Banning of a huge
social media one of the biggest social
media apps in this country they're using
that as leverage against China and it's
support for Russia
yeah I mean I love Tick Tock and I
actually supported being here and it's
in a very effective tool for China
because I mean how many of these tick
tocks do you watch of the of the couples
having dinner and then they're they're
tricking each other and or you watch the
you've seen the videos of of uh the the
actual Chinese government lady that sits
there and teaches you how to speak
Chinese I mean they're they're it's a
tremendous Outreach opportunity for them
and they're using it they are using it
man and I actually don't have a problem
with the way it's shaken out with our
government Banning it on our on on
government platforms and whatnot not
letting that
you know
complement kind of opportunity happen I
have no problem with that if you want to
ban it on government phones whatever but
yeah no it's you're absolutely right it
is a far more uh far bigger stick than
this whole Lab leak thing yeah I mean
because we can say all day long we
believe this is what happened they're
not going to ever give us physical proof
that it happened ever right the idea
that we can get um reassurance from Tick
Tock USA and back up that and have
accountable
um uh accountability for that
reassurance for the data of American
citizens that's much easier than trying
to go over to China to figure out what
the [__] happened with this with
covid-19 and where it came from I mean
maybe we'll know in 20 30 years
um if China ever lets loose of that
evidence but I doubt they will ever love
most of that evidence and it's just Math
Man I mean that's what that's what the
other departments are saying okay well
this could have happened we know two
people from the lab got sick went to the
hospital we can't go over there and we
can't track these cases because of the
idiot diplomacy of the Trump
Administration we had people on the
ground there to do that kind of stuff we
can't do it anymore
it's just I it's frustrating as hell
this whole you know circular [__]
firing squad that goes on in regards to
China it really is I mean China is never
going to give us that information so
other departments say look
other than the actual proof
we have to tell you numbers wise it is
way more likely that it was transmission
from an animal to a person because
mathematically the odds are much greater
you know
but yeah that really happened those two
people really got sick and they're not
really not giving us information on how
they got sick it doesn't really flesh
out but we can't tell you that
because we can't give you proof
it's just a supposition so we have to
tell you mathematically yeah it's a lot
more likely somebody got bit by a bat or
ate a disease bat or however the hell it
transmitted
I I um angry now I want to switch topics
here and I know my transitions may may
be [__] today I and I apologize nice
busy Newsday man but I got so much [__]
to get to this is one thing um that I
want to show Abigail Disney uh posted
this about and I I've been reading a
little bit about this uh Jessa Duggar
reveals that she suffered miscarriage
now I I wanna I Wanna Give the audience
an idea here at my stance on this my
stance is I don't give a [__] if Jessa
Duggar uh received an abortion or she
had a you know if she suffered a
miscarriage and had to get health care
because of it I actually think we should
be making sure that Jessa Duggar as a
woman has the capability of choosing her
health care and getting the health care
she needs the health care that she needs
to
um
to make sure that she's healthy and safe
um Abigail Duggar points out here she
says our excuse me Abigail Disney points
out about Jessa Duggar she says she
didn't have a miscarriage she had a DNC
um which is also called an abortion and
would be illegal in many states under
law she herself supports now for [__]
sake at least just tell the truth
um now this is it's illegal in Arkansas
where she lives right this is a family
and we got Gabe Sanchez with us too and
I know I know Gabe Sanchez will have an
opinion on this but um um here's the
thing I actually I I am glad that she
was able to receive the procedures that
she received I'm just sad that her
family uh is one of the biggest
promoters of other women that don't look
like her non-white people
um and poor people not to get not to get
these procedures to help uh in their in
their choice for Health Care uh so
excuse me if I feel a little unsorry for
Jessa Duggar about her [__] revealing
that she had a miscarriage when really
honestly I I think this is a DNC the
more I read about it the procedure that
she had
um is a DNC now she shouldn't be drug
over this well right well not not just
her but all pro-lifers everywhere
because why aren't they banishing her
why aren't they speaking out against her
and the reason why is because her family
is is well I mean her brother's in the
[__] federal prison for diddling kids
um which you know we could go there but
her family has been a huge supporter of
stripping away women's rights to make
decisions the same decision that Jessa
Duggar made for her health care uh but
Abigail Disney
um again points out that it might be a
DNC now I'm I'm not a woman right so
that's why I don't want to tell women
what the [__] to do because I don't know
[__] about [__] when it comes to their
health care especially with their
[__] their bodies because I don't has
one like that and I don't knows anything
about that I feel that women and their
doctors have a much um better time of
making those choices that's why I'm for
women having Choice here
um but again you know D and C or no DNC
[__] Jess the Duggar and [__] anyone
who's crying about how anyone's dragging
her can you agree Gabe or am I am I just
an [__]
yeah if you unmute your mic it might
help
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
always always
Daniel anyway uh yeah dude dragger
that's totally fine yes you're an
[__] uh but wow both right both yeah
both can be true right
um but I look at this and I when you
when you have someone
that compares abortions to the Holocaust
right and members of her family who have
described themselves as conservative
right
and then you
on the other side right you have the
benefit and the luxury to get a
procedure done that not many people can
get and uh a a is illegal in the state
that you live because your family has
been pushing these policies and
reflecting people for years to do that
and so it's kind of the [__] Beyond I
mean Beyond I mean also that but also
there's like the decreasing number of uh
of people that can get this procedure
right because of their family lobbying
and because of other conservative
Republicans I mean
there's another
side to this which
I haven't really seen too many people
talking about and it's about the
accessibility right if it's illegal to
do that thing in that state then doctors
are going to say and have been saying
well what's the point of me working in
the State anymore right if I can't do
what I'm supposed to do as an OB GYN and
actually help the the
the health and well-being of a mother
and her potential child then what's the
point of working in the state right and
we've seen doctors who have moved to
other states now what you're also going
to see is there's going to be outbreaks
of
different health conditions that happen
you know um there was a syphilis
outbreak that happened uh we're gonna
find similar stuff that happens with
children because you have people who are
not trained well right who go to school
because the other thing too is they're
not only saying that it's illegal but as
part of your rotation when you're
getting trained in the medical field to
become a doctor you have to go through
and work with different groups right in
one of those groups is Women's Health
and specifically OB GYN learning you
know about everything that goes that is
involved with that everything from
abortion to these procedures DNC
everything so if you're telling me right
now it's illegal as a doctor let's say
I'm a doctor it's illegal I can't
actually practice that in that state
which means I can't get certified as uh
and you know by the medical board
because I haven't actually fulfilled the
training required so you're going to
have people who are less qualified who
don't know you know their ass from their
hand and they're going to be dealing
with children enforcing these children
into you know to come into the world
where they don't have the proper
resources funding or medical
professionals to actually handle the
situation and you're gonna find kids are
going to be sick
they're gonna have conditions they're
gonna have this they're gonna have that
because nobody knows how to follow each
trimester make sure you're great you
have these things you're taking the
right supplements you're taking the
right nutrients the baby's health is
okay your health is okay
we don't we won't have that in certain
States anymore and the more that it
becomes illegal for abortions to happen
you're going to it's not just the end
result which is
you know I'm pregnant and I uh you know
I want an abortion it's all the way back
at the beginning which is the person who
has to guide you through those nine
months on the medical side can't become
certified to actually help you so
there's a decreasing number and also
people just leaving because they're like
look I have a passion for this field and
I want to help women and I want to help
babies come into this world but I can't
do in the state or else I'm arrested so
I'm going to go somewhere else and we're
gonna find that's gonna keep happening
right well and I want to make one more
point because the chat lit up about a
DNC and what a DNC is and a DN because a
lot of women are weighing in which I
appreciate
um because it is it is your knowledge
about your choice and your health care
but I want to make this point about a
DNC or miscarriage or pregnancy uh in
general this is not about what this is
specifically to me uh and it shouldn't
be to all Americans who are watching
their their wives their sisters their
daughters their mothers being stripped
of their right to their choice of health
care and that's the main point is
whether it's it whether it's a DNC
because of a miscarriage or just a DNC
or abortion or whatever the hell you
want to call it whatever the hell it is
the idea that Jessa Doug Duggar because
her white privilege in Arkansas and her
family is [__] pushed for years and
years and years to make sure that women
like her don't have access to health
care that she gets access to that's the
story here that that's the [__] point
and that we should make sure that we
frame this up to Jessa Duggar doesn't
have any other privilege to get these
procedures in these Health in this
health care that any other woman should
get in Arkansas or anywhere else so so
spare me the whole oh poor Jessa Duggar
she's been it's been mischaracterized
and all that [__] [__] that [__] [__]
her and [__] every Duggar out there that
isn't speaking against that family I
mean honestly if you're not speaking if
you're your last name's Duggar and
you're an Arkansas you're part of this
family you're not speaking against them
you're complicit in this [__] especially
with your brother so you know
um Billy Bob Billy Joe or whatever the
[__] well she she admitted it herself
she said she had a curettage and that's
what the C and D and C stands for it's
dilate and curitage the the other if you
look up an abortion there's no actual
medical procedure called an abortion if
you look up an abortion it says c d and
c c d and e d and e is a dilating and
evacuation I mean she said herself she
had an abortion and there are some
people in the chat that are trying to
say well it's not really an abortion if
if it's if it's a part of a miscarriage
no it's just an abortion of a dead fetus
wow that's what it is but that's the
point I'm trying to make is no matter
what designation you give it it's
[__] Health Care yeah and that's the
point that's the point it's Women's
Health Care and when you're when you're
[__] with that you're [__] with
liberty and when you're [__] with
Liberty you get on the wrong side of me
and you get on the fighting side of me
and that's what pisses me off speaking
on the fighting side of me oh I did want
to I saw someone that asked about uh the
syphilis outbreak I was talking about it
was in Arkansas it was actually it's a
it's in Mississippi and the specifics of
it over the last five years I was trying
to remember what the percentage was but
over the last five years uh there's been
a number of babies in Mississippi that
have been treated for congenial syphilis
that has jumped more than 900 percent
um and it really does show you that in
some of the poorest states in our in our
country right especially the states that
rely so heavily
on Blue States you know for funding
federal tax dollars so when when
Margaret Taylor green says we got her to
get a national divorce you're gonna [__]
over those like if the compounding
interest of how much you [__] over the
red States who are already low with
resources funding and medical
professionals you're going to now double
down if not triple down I mean like the
the
the amount of lack of Health Care and
the child's well-being and just just
that topic alone is is compounded
because you're now removing any sort of
funding so when Margarita green says
[__] like we need a national divorce and
we need to [__] separate this and
this
you're gonna she's gonna [__] over her
own state but also States like
Mississippi which have their own problem
right now
yeah and I I'll make it real quick Tony
what what Gabe said earlier every day
you have a certain number of
gynecologists that leave your state
either through retirement moving or
whatever you need to have new
gynecologists coming in to fit to fill
their ranks and what red states have
learned is they [__] up badly because
of exactly what Gabe was saying because
you cannot finish your clinicals you
cannot you cannot get your license to
practice because you cannot
actually practice all of the
requirements that the board requires for
you to become a gynecologist because
they outlawed dnc's they outlaw dnes and
the red States
we'll just send women to pediatricians
then I mean that's in the red States you
know yeah why not why not they I mean
they don't you know red States doesn't
want to have uh that's really good
Healthcare anyway so just send them to a
pediatrician why not and it's also you
know it's no different and you know
Texas Paul brings up a good point is
it's just a replacement right which is
the same thing
it's no different than the 87 000 IRS
agents we're replacing people who are
retiring replacing people who are moving
up in the ranks We're getting people
entry level to help go through and
actually audit and take calls and
customer service things like that wait
you mean that was a lie come on you're
I'm just saying I'm just saying about a
party that supports this guy
like there was some sort of planning and
protocol on how we should do this and
Republicans are like no no no regulation
get rid of it right placement get rid of
it what speaking of Regulation because
um I man I this these freeze frames that
I've got here lately are awesome I gotta
say but um speaking of Regulation
someone who doesn't understand
regulation and tax and how [__] works
and markets
um this guy I don't know if you know
this uh fellas and audience this guy
ruined ruined during his four years
Administration ruined
long-standing trade Partnerships that
farmers had with China absolutely
destroyed turned his back on farmers and
destroyed but did you tell me when he
started when he when he threw in those
tariffs tariffs when he threw those
turfs he was he was not helping America
no um he wasn't and he wasn't helping
people you know what you know what's
funny you know what's funny Hogs and
soybeans in particular well uh also the
lumber industry
um I don't know if people know this but
all the [__] that comes from China
that's made with cedar or or pine they
don't they don't we harvest the Cedar
and pine here we ship it and sell it to
them over there they build the [__] and
then they send it back over here for us
to buy I don't know if anyone knows that
so we're not just talking when I say
farmer I don't just mean [__]
growing corn and cattle okay I mean all
sorts of Industry that is Rule [__]
remote Indus history and particularly
the lumber industry this [__]
puts out a thing yesterday not only
doubling down tripling and quadrupling
down basically saying we will trade
nothing with China and they will trade
nothing with us within four years which
is [__] bone-headed at best but this
idea that we're not going to have a
trade partnership with China is [__]
delusional I mean absolutely a [__]
bolt-faced lion delusion that you think
within four years maybe 40 maybe 400 it
can all be untangled but there is no
[__] way that the economy will stand
the way it stands now by by tearing
apart our trade partnership that we have
with China they rely on us we rely on
them as much as they may be our enemy
and they may be spying on us with tick
tag or whatever we're reliant on each
other we're Partners in this [__] in
this garbage it just when we're talking
about consumerism but let me let me play
you a little bit of the this dumbass's
statement here and I'll tell you why
it's horrible for his voters but they're
not going to give a [__] listen we will
phase in a system Universal Baseline
tariffs on most foreign products on top
of this higher tariffs will increase
incrementally depending on how much
individual foreign countries devalue
their currency they devalue their
currency to take advantage of the United
States as tariffs on foreign producers
go up taxes on American Producers will
go down and go down very substantially
and that means a lot of jobs coming in
not only will this system end our gaping
trade deficits and they are massive
right now again I I know I don't want to
get into too many um uh what do you call
them facts but but when you're talking
about trade deficits it has nothing to
do with how much money we get or don't
get that is not that is not a thing
that's not even a [__] close to a
thing of how much money we get and how
much money they get in a deficit that
it's not how a trade deficit works it is
just the difference between what we what
we trade to them and what they trade
back to us it has nothing to do with our
GDP at the deficit that is of our trade
I just want to point that out and every
Economist says deficits are [__]
well I mean I mean deficits don't have
an effect on how well the economy does
or how well it doesn't do yeah they
don't reflect reality it's like the old
pineapple example you know if you've got
it uh if Hawaii was its own country they
grow [__] pineapples we make tractors
we're going to sell them a tractor every
10 years but we're going to buy
pineapples from them every year and run
a trade deficit does it matter [__]
no we want the pineapples you know trade
deficits are a [__] fiction right
well it's deficits in general are are
[__] dumb because it's just a
measurement of nothing that actually
affects the actual Commerce but let's
listen to how he's going to [__] Farmers
here this is beautiful oh my God this is
great and they don't even say it and see
it because he doesn't actually say it
out loud but listen [__] jobs it will
also bring trillions and trillions of
dollars pouring into these things from
foreign countries no it'll bring
trillions and trillions of dollars in
tears from us people who pay to get the
[__] into the country because if Hawaii
was its own country and you want [__]
Pineapple on your goddamn Pizza you're
gonna pay more for the [__] Pineapple
to get it on your [__] pizza if they
were your if they were a foreign [__]
country it's it's it's just nonsense he
doesn't even understand that the Tariff
is not paid by China it's paid by us
when we bring this [__] here the other
the other thing is uh and it's not and
it's not just farming like I have
personal experience in the actual like
manufacturing and configuring of of
computer hardware right microchips uh
microcontrollers I'm glad you brought
that up because uh remind me to play
Pete butterjudge yeah yeah and so
uh I remember specifically with the one
of the companies I was at when I you
know working within the iot space right
we we rely heavily on these uh
components that go together
um to build the hardware that we need
that go inside of the scooters that you
see on the street or the you know Amazon
uh Alexa that you've got you know or
whatever or yeah whatever you've got
that connects to the internet like we
were the ones who are manufacturing that
Hardware
and so uh when Trump was like oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna tariff the [__] out of
China to show them what's going on well
there was a whole thing about like what
was pre-configured right what was made
beforehand or what were just component
wise
he put a an unnecessary tax right and
it's why people were like oh [__] we
have to leave China and now we have to
build in Taiwan and build up factories
there because China like in Shenzhen the
district there which is like where you
get all the electronics right it's one
of the biggest manufacturers exactly and
so a lot of a lot of companies are
specifically we need to set up Factory
we need to set up a factory somewhere
else like the the tariffs on us to get
these components is out the ass because
we're getting charged the tax on our end
which we you know as a company we're
like well in order to survive that means
that we would have to raise the tax or
the price for the components on our
clients and we lose them so we had to
look and say all right we can continue
to manufacture them in China for the
time being but we need to look at Taiwan
as an alternate to set up shop there and
actually yes and the chips Act is
something else that is helping to
manufacture them uh within the United
States because we are so far booming in
Arizona and booming in there to be clear
the chips Act is not only to help what
Gabe is talking about but it's also to
prevent something when a I don't know
like a pandemic happens and and which
makes which exacerbates the problem that
you're talking about right um and and
bottlenecks the ability for us to
actually manufacture other things here
like we aren't able to manufacture
things here without [__] computer
chips I mean one of the things that
chips exactly and the chips Act is
something that will definitely help with
that I know specifically like if anyone
remembers or has read about it which was
the so many cars that have specific
pieces of Hardware those chips inside
them that cannot function without so
basically sitting on the assembly line
because we did not have we had a
shortage and you know through all of the
all of the amount of xenophobia and
isolationism that Trump had during his
administration we're now trying to
course correct uh you know we're doing
it as fast as we can but we're also
trying to make sure that we plan it
massively contributed to to the
inflation that happened after Kobe
massively because what what what what
Gabe is talking about and what makes it
so bad is it sandwiches one top on top
of each other it's not just the cost of
the chip it it it it is every component
ends up getting uh an additional you
know because of the the way tariffs
cause inflation each component gets
considerably more expensive and by the
time you end up with the finished
product you don't have a product that's
15 more expensive you got a product that
can be 50 more expensive it can be a
hundred percent more expensive that's
why tariffs are always the last resort
always yeah right well and they're used
they're used in uh the proper way to use
them is is is not to punish a country
but to punish a product
um Obama did this very well with tires
and drywall I don't know if you guys
know this about tire and drywall there
was a ton of [__] tires and a ton of
[__] drywall that was coming from China
we couldn't stop it it was just a deluge
of this garbage I mean drywall that was
discontinued because it was [__]
poison and people were handed in their
houses radioactive right so so
um so the Obama Administration used the
Tariff to stop the drywall from coming
here that's how they stopped it because
you can't stop it by normal Market means
because it is a free trade market right
so you can't stop it by that so a tariff
is designed to stop products not to
punish a company all right excuse me a
country it's not that's not what it's
used for and he's a [__] idiot and
doesn't understand that doesn't
understand that what he's talking about
is the Mercantile system yeah it hasn't
been used in a long time but let me let
me show you what he's saying about
Farmers because I think this is the most
significant thing he says in uh and it's
in the last part of this here but he
says it and it's it it's gonna hurt his
[__] supporters like instantaneously
if he were to do this like
instantaneously which he won't because
he will never be president again because
of us because of the country that we
[__] hate this guy this guy's a toxic
more of a toxic sludge on America than
than Norfolk Southern is in Ohio
to invest that money in American workers
I will Implement a bold series of
reforms to completely eliminate
dependence on China in all critical
areas we will revoke China's most
favored nation trade status and adopt a
four-year plan to phase out all Chinese
Imports of essential Goods everything
from Electronics to Steel to
Pharmaceuticals we will also adopt okay
if you don't understand exactly what I I
just said earlier about like Lumber
which is a very specific product when we
can't when a fun when when Lumber
Harvesters Lumber Farmers cannot and the
lumber industry cannot Harvest lumber at
a rate to stay alive for a profit margin
to pay their workers and to actually
produce a profit they can't send it
anywhere but China just because those
products can't come back here okay so so
they can't send Lumber to China to be
made as something that we buy to be sent
back here because that product can't be
sent back here it's really [__] dumb
the other way he's gonna hurt farmers is
this new rules to stop U.S companies
from pouring investments into China and
to stop China from buying up America
allowing all of those Investments That
clearly Serve American interests we're
not going to allow bad things to happen
to our country anymore and we will
eliminate Federal contracts for any
company that outsources to China but
what he's saying here in in a nutshell
is that that we will stop trade with
China which I'm sure that's just gonna
oh I'm sure Farmers this morning if they
heard this which they didn't because
he's an idiot
um and he you know a couple about a
million two million people saw it and
the majority of that is People Like Us
who give a [__] about what this [__]
[__] box is saying so we can stop him
but the people who need to hear this are
not going to hear this Texas ball
they're not going to [__] hear this
they're going to stay in their Echo
Chambers they're gonna they're not gonna
realize that this bonehead is [__]
saying as soon as I become as soon as
you elect me present I'm gonna make it
tougher on you vote for me Donald Trump
who is anti-farmer
same [__] idiots talking about the
wall will will not be you know even if
they Hear It They'll dismiss it you know
right and and I think that's there's a
and I think when people talk about
tariffs they want to hear about tariffs
I don't think they understand that
basically what happens is like when you
do it to us we'll do it to you situation
right it becomes this like
sometimes it can become but it's exactly
what China did to us
and so yeah Donald Trump uh you know and
I and I just want to go back to the
electronic side of it is when he did
when when basically he did that then
China was like okay fine we'll do the
same right so basically they're like
well in order to pay those tariffs you
have to pay these tariffs so we can
cover our cost and then it becomes again
this pissing contest of like all right
well if I tear of you then you tear of
me but I'm going to tear a few on the
tariffs that you tariff me with and I'm
going to tear a few on the tariffs that
you terrify me with that I tear if you
want well that's that's why pork that's
why the pork industry took a [__]
kick in the asses because that was one
of the first things that that Gigi ping
went after was pork because he knew that
would directly Target Trump's [__]
voter base is to punish them and guess
what Trump did he gave them the biggest
[__] socialist payment any president
has ever written out in that time in
history to the farmers of America and he
bought their vote uh well hold on I
thought Trump said anytime he spoke to
China he was the one who was controlling
the conversation yeah right have you
ever seen Gigi ping have you ever seen
him talk to people have you ever watched
his [__] his close advisors talk to
people it's not a situation where that
person wants to hear what that
motherfucker's saying that [__]
is the king over there he's the one that
rules that's probably why Donald Trump
says that he wants to be he's like oh
you're King you're King right I want to
be just like you right because Trump is
still not Trump is still not one Farmers
back over either they [__] hate him
those checks these were were just like
pissing on a farmer's boots man they
were like I am not in the farming
business to collect [__] welfare that
is not why I'm here I am here to raise
Hogs and I'm here to raise soybeans and
this [__] check does it one doesn't
cover my expenses and two I'm here to
sell [__] soybeans and that's what I
was doing last year until this dumb
[__] did what he did and farmers have
not forgotten it man I'm telling you
they are looking at DeSantis really
freaking hard man I want to disagree
with you here and the point that I want
to disagree with you on is the word
farmer because what you're saying is a
family farmer not a corporate farmer
corporate Farmers I don't know if you
know this they [__] love socialism
they [__] oh my God they love
government payments their entire design
of their corporate Farms are to get more
subsidies they design their profit
models after our [__] tax dollars a
hundred percent why do you think they
they back Republicans to take the
welfare check and and food stamps out of
the farm bill because they don't want
they don't want that part of the farm
bill they want the farm bill that
benefits them the most and and they
don't consider that welfare they
consider that insurance right that's the
way they sell it to themselves well I
under I understand that but but that
that is not true on their on their when
they're when they're doing their their
line item items when they're looking at
their accounting and their accountants
going through it with them they're
they're super excited about that
government payment it doesn't matter
what you want to [__] call it uh
insurance or not and if and if that's
the thing we got to change then then we
need to start changing that that it's
not Insurance you [__] toxic sludge
idiots it's [__] socialism you're the
farmers in this country are the original
class of socialists in this country that
is who they are that at their core your
Granddaddy's granddaddy was a [__]
socialist dummy
um we want it that way we really do want
it that way absolutely it's a Guaranteed
Supply of food people right I want I
would I would like to have food more
socialized and what I mean by that is to
make sure every child in this country
eats every [__] day every [__] day
A child should not go hungry one goddamn
meal no matter how we have to deliver it
no matter what we have to do I don't
give a [__] we should make sure that
children [__] eat because that's our
that's our next generation and without
nutrition they're we're [__]
um speaking of the administration doing
things as opposed to not doing things or
hurting the economy like for tariffs
that Donald Trump wants to do here's uh
mayor Pete he's a do nothing we've been
told this week he's a he's a faker he's
not doing anything he's not doing his
job oh my God he's he's hurting
Americans all kinds of crazy [__] well
uh mayor Pete even in the suit and tie
is out here in Kansas
um Kansas I said that right it's a red
State it's a red State
Democrats do go and do support Americans
in red States no matter what Fox News
will tell you uh secretary I mean they
definitely don't take the Jared Kushner
approach which is [__] over the blue
States right we care for the United
States well I mean this current
Administration and Pete bootage
especially understands coming from a red
State because he's from the state of
Indiana
um Coming uh that that all states are an
integral part of this country and there
are no real borders when we come to
States other than how far the those laws
are reaching to those borders because in
all actuality is one economy it is one
it is one push for this country and we
can't ignore rule America the the reason
why they're so pissed off is because
they've been voting Republicans so long
and Republicans have been ignoring their
economies for so long
but but [__] mind [__] them and
deluding them to think that it's
Democrats fault not Republican's fault
but here I hear I'll tell you uh
secretary Pete from his official
accounts is touring the site of what
will be one of the biggest EB battery
factories in the world
um right here in Desoto Kansas not not
Manhattan New York not somewhere in
libtard California in Kansas well it's
definitely not going to be like the um
the Foxconn manufacturing or the factory
that they that they planned and promised
to be this big extravagant American jobs
thousands will be employed in Wisconsin
uh and then it turns out that it was
much less and you know they got played
in in the end deal yeah giveaway
billions in tax credits and got nothing
if you look at this picture they're
breaking ground here folks this is not a
like Gabe says this is not a figment
Factory where they're going to promise
to show up and never do they are
building this Factory right now and like
I was saying earlier with the
semiconductors Arizona is booming uh
taiwan's largest manufacturer has said
look we're really close to China they
can really interfere with our production
we want to we want to diversify where we
build and they're they're building those
factories in in Arizona right now those
Fabs are going up in Arizona like crazy
Intel also Qualcomm also just all I mean
I'm telling you that Joe's killing it
well you know what what else I think is
funny about this video because
um this is really good this is really
good for Elon Musk and Tesla like really
good uh I I am I imagine that Tesla
eventually will not be manufacturing a
lot of cars though because they one
thing that Tesla does and Gabe can uh
attest to this is they are really good
at building solar and charging stations
like they're going to be an integral
part even as much as I hate Elon Musk
they're going to be an integral part of
building the EV infrastructure in this
country that is one reason why the car
manufacturers are had been and will
continue to box Elon Musk out of the car
market
um is because they want the car market
they want Elon to build the
infrastructure that's what they want I
mean you got to know your place in the
market and when there's big control and
big money and big Capital they're going
to make you but this video here from
mayor Pete he's talking about a battery
Factory that is going to be built for Ev
vehicles
um but Evie is gonna is gonna be our
life not just with vehicles but it's
going to go well beyond that solar is
the new uh Power here we thought it was
going to be wind wind is an integral
part of power in this country but I
believe solar is uh is going to outshine
not to no pun intended
um outshine win but let's listen to
Mayor P so we're in Desoto Kansas at the
site of
a battery Factory putting 4
good paying jobs here in Desoto Kansas
we're so excited about the return of
manufacturing jobs to the U.S 800 000
good paying manufacturing jobs created
since President Biden took office and
more where that came from like what you
see behind it believe in making sure
that America competes and wins
especially in the battle for the EV
future and there's so many places
especially in the middle of the country
that felt forgotten felt Left Behind who
are now going to be able to win
economically because of the work that we
are doing and the local leaders on the
ground I can't wait to see this become a
reality and can't wait to see more and
more of the good paying jobs being
created across the United States become
a reality too okay Texas Paul I'm going
to go to you on this because you are a
union gay but I want to say um because I
don't talk about unions much here I
really I don't feel like I need to but
the one reason why Republicans hate this
the one reason why Republicans were
against this they do not want this big
manufacturing age that we're coming into
for electric vehicles is because what it
makes way for is that people realize
that they're trading away their labor
for capital in this country which only
creates this idea of labor unions and it
creates this idea that we should be paid
and we should get the pay that we
deserve that is why Republicans do not
want these factories to return it's only
their hopes and dreams to tell their
constituents and oh it was them damn
Democrats and them unions that took your
factories away and we'll bring them back
wink
um when it's actually the Democrats that
want the manufacturing it always has
been the Liberals that want the
manufacturer they want the freedom they
want the ability to give the capital to
these communities in these states by the
form of Labor
um and and that is really truly what
Republicans are scared of is in Desoto
Kansas they're going to be a big huge
Factory it's going to open it's going to
have 4 000 employees and what it's going
to do is it's going to turn it's going
to turn people into them damn Democratic
voters what says you about the union and
how this is so important for American
workers
yeah I mean you're absolutely right
politically Republicans hate this stuff
you know even though they're going into
their backyard and they're going to
claim credit for it later they really do
hate this stuff because I mean the more
manufacturing we get we get back the
stronger unions will be and the Bluer
people tend to vote when when they've
got a factory job I mean they just they
just do I mean they they understand the
benefits they start to understand you
know when you when when you take Billy
Bob off the farm and you put them on on
an assembly line he suddenly learns what
benefits are and who's working for them
to have them and who's working to take
them away and you're absolutely right
Republicans despise that
I couldn't agree more I I mean that's
but but I mean this is why they fought
so hard against getting manufactured
this is why they hate the chip sack
that's why they hate the infrastructure
bill this is why they don't want rule
Broadband they don't want rule Broadband
folks they don't want it and the reason
why is because it delivers information a
hell of a lot quicker and it gets the
truth to people a hell of a lot quicker
than their [__] lies on Fox News well
they don't they don't uh I mean like we
also need to I mean on top of that like
remember that the reason that
Republicans fear these things right is
because
you've got Tucker Carlson who talks
about you know uh
uh January 6 committee and the ruling
class is telling us normal people what
we should believe in you know and it's
it's ironic and there's a bunch of
projection in statements like that as an
example but Republicans they fear those
things because what happens is if you
educate and you give that knowledge and
you and you uh share those experiences
with people to say like oh [__] my life
could have been better years ago year I
could have had these benefits I could
have had access to the health care I
could have I could have not [__]
worked 80 hours Broken my back twice
done all of these all of these things
and still had to work or like force this
or done that
it's that aspect of if you let them know
how life or how good life can be
then they'll never want to go back to
the way that you had it before and right
now is Republicans have it under a way
under a guise of
no no this stuff is bad right this this
socialist program this this type of
benefits or what have you are all bad
because these are going to be the
results right and people who haven't
experienced the benefits of actually
working at a company that cares for you
working with a union that actually
protects your rights you know uh in a
regulated industry that doesn't Force
labor on children you know
um it's one of those things where if
those people actually knew and could
experience themselves oh yeah they
[__] flip on a sec in a moment's
notice they'll be like oh well hold on
why have I been doing it this way for 30
years I could have retired by now and
had all of these things uh given to me
or accessible and now I'm just realizing
at whatever my age is and knowing that
what life could have been right because
as as soon as those people realize how
good life can be
with government social programs jobs
benefits whatever they will never return
back to the way that the ruling class
AKA Republicans have it which is low
wages no benefits poor conditions
uh remove any sort of access to learning
internet books what have you keep them
dumb and keep them done for their whole
life because then they'll not know they
will not know any better and that's
their goal speaking of dumb that's a
great transition here um because I want
to show you the difference because
everyone's been doubting me uh not just
here in the audience uh I don't think
the audience down to me on social media
and then people personally that I talk
to on a daily basis they're really
doubting me that Donald Trump's gonna be
the [__] nominee and that Joe Biden's
gonna whip his ass but I want to show
you some examples one of the examples is
just what I showed you the difference in
I don't know like the outcome of the
economy and how important labor is
Donald Trump's like I'm gonna make sure
you can't trade anything with China and
I'm gonna make sure nothing can come
back over here and people to judge is
like well we'll just build a factory
here to build batteries yeah here the
thing that I promise to do not [__]
overseas right what wages and not cut
the the actual funding to say like oh
it'll be cheaper if you do it over over
like abroad
you know this is this is you know
conservatives Republicans are like oh
made in America show me one Republican
who actually who has actually built or
supported something that has been made
in America all of these projects that
Joe Biden is doing around those are
American manufacturing jobs to build
those factories to build those companies
that will then employ American workers
who who learn a whole new skill set and
that is called job security well I'm
going to show you Republican in this
clip that does not that that's not going
to tell you any of that
um and then I'm going to show you I'm
gonna but I'm going to show you evidence
of why Donald Trump is going to be the
nominee and why he is going to lose
um this is Paul Ryan I don't know if you
know Paul Ryan is he used to be the
speaker of the house
um yeah he's Eddie Munster yeah that
[__] idiot um but here it I don't
know if anyone knows this too he is he
is on the board of directors of Fox News
so that's very important too context
here as well listen to what what Paul
Ryan has to say about Donald Trump is
going to be the nominee listen I'm a
never again Trumper because I want to
win they're going to lose with him look
okay okay all right all right everyone
keeps doubting me they keep saying
Saints is going to get in Santa's gonna
beat Trump [__] [__] you are not
you do not you are not paying attention
the party leaders are saying Trump will
be the nominee he is going to lose and
not only is he going to lose we are
going to lose as a result and I am here
for it
desantos has no entry into this race
none his little stunt with Disney
yesterday which it was a stunt by the
way
is not is not enough it's not enough to
work up enough courage for him to enter
this race even as even people around him
are saying well if he does announce it
won't be till June Jesus Christ you're
gonna wait till June he ain't he's
waiting to see if Donald Trump's gonna
die because that's the only way Donald
Trump doesn't win this and Paul Ryan
just said it we will lose with him when
he becomes the nominee let's continue
the evidence is pretty clear we lost the
house in 18 because of trump yeah we
lost the presidency obviously we lost
the senate in 20 because sure then there
are I by my account five Senate seats
this cycle in 22 we lost because of
trump yeah and by most sort of smart
people in our party smart people in our
party that is hilarious that Paul Ryan
who used to be this speaker of the house
is like there's no smart people left in
our party they just don't exist that's
hilarious most of their measurements we
lost about 12 to 15 seats in the house
because of trump so Kevin McCarthy would
have had a nice
20-some vote cushion had an opera for
Trump so the point I'm making is we know
we lose with him and so we know we will
lose with him again if we nominate this
guy especially and January 6 happened
after the 20 election
so you think it became more popular with
swing voters in the wild counties you
know since January 6. so my point is
we're going to lose with the guy so
let's move we're gonna lose with the guy
because Texas ball I I know me and
you've been saying it since the
beginning of the year and Gabe I think
agreed to this Donald Trump is going to
be their nominee who the [__] else is it
going to be and Paul Ryan's all but
admitting in here don't you think Texas
ball
yeah
um no he uh
I I I believe that he's actually going
to be their nominee because the guy
isn't like you know DeSantis is weak you
know this [__] he pulled yesterday with
in Florida with with uh with Disney is a
[__] joke it's because Bob Iger
stuffed him in a damn locker and put him
in his place and he's got to try to it's
a stick man I'm a tough guy I'm a tough
guy even though he's completely backed
off everything with Disney he's not
going to do a damn thing with Disney the
show is all it was and the media it
always is he's actually doing something
they're like oh that's why he really
stuck into Disney in the media I'm like
what are you talking about he didn't do
[__] he didn't change anything let's
let's remember that Rhonda Santos also
got married at Disney World okay is that
real yeah are you serious
what a woke libtard 2000 in 2009. you
think the guy weak enough so freaking
weak that he has to invent fake fights
like gas stoves and [__] like that where
nobody's fighting back the other
direction to try to seem like a tough
guy is really going to get in that [__]
pit with Donald Trump and come out a
winner
no Donald Trump doesn't swing back
Donald Trump [__] slices your goddamn
hamstring when you're trying to get in
the pit man he is [__] brutal about
this [__] he really is that's that's why
his base is so stuck to him because they
don't give a [__] about what he does or
what happens to the country or anything
else all they give a [__] is that he
tries to hurt liberals that's all they
care about he's really [__] doesn't
give a [__] psychopath brutal and and
nobody else is going to get in there and
fight it out with them they're just not
I got a [__] for everything here and
here's a clip of exactly what you're
talking about and even the voters know
that there's no way that Ron DeSantis
beats Trump because that's that's the
thing folks everyone keeps saying oh
well this bass will turn on him I'm like
yeah okay maybe maybe but they're gonna
vote for the person who think they think
is gonna win that is who they're gonna
vote for they're gonna vote for the
person who they think is going to win
and even if your Rhonda Santa's
supporter you don't believe that he's
going to win a [__] street fight with
Donald Trump no [__] way he's already
calling him a pedophile watch this Fox
News here's Brian Kilmeade trying to
figure out they're in Florida okay this
is [__] Florida they're at a goddamn
Republican Cafe I don't think they let
you in without being a republican card
holder in this [__] place
um you definitely don't want to let you
in unless you're right apparently I mean
I I'm not saying I'm just saying it
doesn't seem that way when you watch the
video you know what I mean
um but watch watch as he's trying to
scramble around trying to find someone
who will say desantos or excuse me
DeSantis as he says he's saying it wrong
any game it's the Santos yeah
Santos like George Santos the
Republicans okay let's let's watch hi
Lawrence first off Metro Diner here I
got a question for you ready
all right
2024 who's pumped up for the election
most of them will be dead who's your man
who's your woman my man Donald Trump
Donald Trump okay Trump two
Christina
Trump four a lot of trump fans not
asking any men I mean any woman oh there
we go Nikki Haley Donald Trump
so far a lot of Donald Trump watch this
this is great I see uh Governor DeSantis
what about President I like it I like it
who's your pick oh gosh I don't know
got into Santa shirt on says it she's a
fan of DeSantis and then when given the
option who would you vote for as
president you go oh I can't I don't know
I can't pick I can't pick Ronnie Ronnie
I made such a [__] ass [__] maybe a
walking billboard for the guy but I
don't know if I doubled down as him as
president you know okay I wanna I wanna
tell the audience out there I want to
reconfirm this this is more evidence
this is the evidence that I'm using to
reach my conclusion Ronda santis will
not be their [__] nominee it is very
unlikely I know the media is telling you
it's gonna be June he's gonna get in
he's doing a book tour it's inevitable
they planned it that way a [__] year
ago when they thought Donald Trump would
be indicted last year and he's not yet
he's not there yet Jack Smith isn't
there yet they thought they Wanda Santos
is planning on his support peeling off
and it's not gonna do it in the
primaries this lady like you said she's
a [__] walking billboard for DeSantis
she's a fan girl
you know she has a trump shirt and she
chose the de Santa shirt to go to this
this white cap excuse me this Cafe and
when asked which one are you going to
support she's like oh [__] probably
Trump right uh the Texas Paul what's
your take on this clip because am I
[__] wrong here is am I just crazy
oh man
there are less of them because of you
know all of the [__] that Trump trump
drives people away so there's a
quantitatively less of these people but
those people are [__] die hard they
lost and they really you know admitting
that you were wrong or meaning admitting
that you back the loser is a really
[__] hard thing to do it's even worse
for sociopaths that that follow Donald
Trump and these people want to prove
that they are not losers that they are
winners and that their guy was the right
choice and they are going to back him a
hundred percent going right down that
[__] drain because we are going to
kick the living [__] out of Donald Trump
in the next election I mean and thank
God I mean because we're just gonna
we're gonna rip ass and take House Seats
back we're going to you
we are going to rip ass and and we're
going to take seats back and we're going
hey because wait wait wait wait these
people really are going to make Trump
for their nominee Xbox I hate that I
hate to be a stickler here on on rip and
whip uh I really hate to do this but and
I know I've got a lot of Clips to get to
but I got to take some time on this rip
ass where I'm from is where you fart
that is what rip where I'm from when you
rip when you whip ass you're you're
kicking someone's ass you're fighting
them but when you rip it you're you're
you're [__] your britches is it the
same where you're at I'm just making
sure
you're a rip and whip ass if I want to
teach you a lesson
I will whip your ass okay if I if I am
[__] done with you and want to make
sure that you are never a [__]
problem again I will rip your ass up I
will I will [__] tear you up okay I
will make you permanently go away that
makes sense because again the phrase rip
ass I mean like you're standing in an
elevator with a bunch of friends you
know maybe even drinking beer and eating
pizza all day just got back from a
football game or some [__] going back to
the hotel room to drink more beer and
you're standing and you know how bad a
beer fart smells oh yeah when you add
pizza and wings on top of that oh my God
we're not talking about farting Marge
man ah okay okay well hey you know what
that's a great transition uh someone you
know we got the petty Yeti here uh
Marjorie foot green it goes by the petty
Eddie but
um
House of petty actually had a video this
morning of a Marge's little um uh her
tweet that she put out about which one
was it there was the one that she was
back in the restaurant yeah um but he
yeah he calls her the hagatron
the hagatron which is [__] hilarious
um so I gotta show this video uh let's
let's go to our official the official uh
news news uh breaking news here of
Marjorie Taylor Greens in the official
report on the hagatron let's listen good
morning it looks like howler monkeys
Spork foot mchagatron is out of the
ground blah blah blah I was attacked at
a restaurant Ben insane women blah blah
blah they have no respect for the
restaurant blah blah blah people used to
respect each other even if they had
different views
Miss hagatron I distinctly remember you
chasing after a Parkland shooting
Survivor I distinctly remember you
tripping my staff are videotaping and
posting it on the internet I remember
just recently you were screaming like a
howler monkey who lost her mind and out
of her ADHD meds at the president of the
United States go ahead go on tell me
again how people have lost their mind
anything's fine
yeah and and not just the [__] she did
at the State of the Union she followed a
kid around when David Hogg was still a
student followed him around and and
taught I mean just [__] verbally
berated a kid uh she kicked another kid
she uh was screaming in the mail slot in
aoc's mail slot I mean this [__] has
done everything before deserve
oh as you say that was before she was a
city she was a representative too
she came to the capital and you know and
after she was a rep she's in there
freaking pasting [__] up on people's
office wall in an office the wall next
to people's office stores this [__] has
earned [__] earned this stuff now I
don't agree with it I don't agree go you
know going and yelling at people in
restaurants and [__] like that if you
want to speak your mind that's one thing
that's that and the other but just
scoring and screaming at people in
Public's just stupid but she earned it
she has 100 earned it I mean yeah
for the stupid because this is this
piece of garbage should never have a
peaceful moment in public oh no she
[__] resigns from Congress because
you resigned I'm I'm for peace but not
Margaret Marjorie Taylor green right uh
she she willingly chose nobody forced
this position on her right nobody said
you have to run you now have to be in a
position and the representative of the
house and you have to have this job
right nobody forced her right nobody
forced her to take the back well uh
nobody forced to take vaccine she took
it yeah there's an opposite of nobody
forced her where do this nobody forced
to do that she she chooses to do these
things right she chose to run
she chose to run again okay
so when she makes videos where she's
like oh man my life is so shitty I don't
make as much money as I used to and it's
not as fun and joyful anymore and I
can't see my family then [__] quit
resign it's as simple as that if you
have these complaints and you're
bitching and you're moaning about how
all of these are problems then don't do
the job right if you're not happy and
you don't find joy in it then leave
right
especially if you can spend more time
with your family and you made more money
but we know that's not true and you're
just complaining for the sake of
complaining because you want to make
your own problem right marjor Taylor
green and other Republicans have this
tendency to make
other people's problems their problems
or make
uh trivial stuff way more exaggerated
and dramatic than it needs to be so they
feel like they can be part of the oh
guys I'm actually hurting too feel sorry
for me right but it's hard to feel sorry
for someone who chases a kid at the age
of 17 I think is what David Hogg was
throughout DC making a video that said
he's paid by you know these people to
come here and do this it's a whole uh
conspiracy these are child these are
crisis actors right this is the person
who wants to complain about other people
in a public space voicing their opinion
about how she is as a representative and
there's two things one I don't [__]
care because she deserves it right it's
not like this person was minding their
own business as a representative and was
like whoa uncalled for that I don't know
why you did that
she brought all of this attention on her
she wants to Spotlight she wants to be
the victim and she wants to find a
relatable story and one people can have
compassion for it's the same reason why
I believe George Santos lied about his
grandparents fleeing the Holocaust lied
about his mom died in 9 11 lied about
losing four employees in the Pulse
Nightclub shooting lied about someone
attempting to assassinate him and
stealing his shoes in his briefcase in
the middle of Fifth Avenue none of those
things happened they're all fabricated
it's all an attempt to make you seem
more attractive as a representative and
people to feel compassion for you the
only problem is you're a shitty human
being and nobody [__] cares about you
and Margaret Taylor Green in that tweet
I 100 guarantee and I will say this
right now Margaret Taylor green I say
that what happened is completely made up
and if you want to sue me for defamation
do it so be it I would love for you to
show me proof evidence video voice a
[__] police report show it to me
prove it doubt me I guarantee you this
thing never happened and she made it up
for people to feel sorry for her mad Mac
um says from YouTube says pipe bomb
Trader green I think you're getting two
different stories that have nothing to
do with each other oink mixed up there
uh man Mac I just I just want to point
that out
um boy we're we're making good time I
was afraid we weren't gonna get all this
[__] in but we're making good we're good
then I'm gonna take some time
think about it think about it Tony how
many tweets you you and Gabe you follow
social media and all the [__] this crazy
ass woman puts out how many videos have
you seen from her where she's walking
around in public and she says oh look at
this look at this horrible thing and
it's [__] [__] it's made up
[__] but she's look at this horrible
thing that's happening here to offend
you Republican people I mean it's not
like she's not a goddamn combatant when
she's out in public because she does it
herself she does it herself she goes out
in public and says oh look look at this
this year buds case right here you know
it's it it's got a B on it and not an R
because they're they're because they
hate Republicans I mean she does [__]
like that man
she [__] just goes out and makes [__]
up she is a public combatant you cannot
cry foul when it goes the other way it
just makes you look like a gigantic wimp
she's a gigantic snowflake she's just
like Ron DeSantis she loves to act like
she's a badass but when somebody punches
you in the [__] mouth bullies go away
and cry and that's what this is her
toddling away and crying because
somebody gave her back her same [__] I
wish I had the clip which and we don't
have time to pull it up because I I'm
gonna move on to uh Tennessee
um actually doing some horrible stuff to
human beings and dehumanizing people in
Tennessee so I'm gonna move to that here
real quick I don't want to miss that
today that that's important and uh did
you know Governor Bill Lee is a is a
drag queen I didn't know if you knew
that but I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
show you that but um I wish I had the
clip of Marjorie Taylor green right
before her election where she's on a
local radio show and that and and the
radio host is challenging her I forget
exactly what she's challenging her and
but it's something really [__] uh
easy uh to just admit and she [__]
she she gets really butt hurt and gets
up and walks out of the radio program we
played it here uh when it happened
because I've always got my uh my how sad
is it
how sad is it Tony that when you said
we're gonna pull up a clip because it's
something really awful that they're
doing to people in Tennessee that my
first thought was
which one I mean there's so many
freaking things that Billy does it's
like I couldn't even guess what we were
going to talk about well here's here's
the thing that everyone's talking about
in Tennessee right now
um is this drag queen Bill where they're
they're dehumanizing people in Tennessee
who dress up
as a different gender now obviously the
focus is not uh women dressing up as men
okay it's not the real focus of this the
real focus is is their insecurity about
they may they may just be attracted to a
female a woman who has a penis we saw
the clip and I believe it was in
Arkansas a couple weeks ago of the
representative who asked a trans woman
doctor if just out of nowhere if she had
a penis because he was really
uncomfortable that he felt attracted to
her if she had a penis now you talking
about bold haircut guy bull haircut yeah
I don't know what no no this guy was
bald what the [__] was his name that
[__] oh that was the guy that would yeah
that he was he said do you have a penis
and everyone's like whoa what the [__]
what and he's like she she says I didn't
say anything about genitalia he said
well you being in here is about
genitalia he's like yeah he was like you
brought it in here and it's like right
she never brought it up here's the thing
here's the thing I want to tell you
these [__] scumbags like this that
are focused on genitalia Matt Walsh I'm
gonna show you a [__] I'm going to
show you another daily wire scumbag clip
from Michael Knowles because he's just
as bad if not worse than Matt Walsh
um but here's the thing they're obsessed
with genitalia because when they see a
woman that is what they think of is the
woman's genitalia that is why they are
super [__] freaked out about a woman
having the wrong genitalia for them
because it's a them problem it's a you
dude if you're worried about my what's
in my pants that's a you [__] problem
that's not a meat problem yeah that is a
you [__] problem okay there was
a huge viral uh Tick Tock that blew up
it was actually a still picture of a guy
uh standing at a funeral a urinal and
he's got a look on his face like what
the [__] and there's a woman standing
next to him that that they're saying is
drag in drag but really is it tizzy just
destroyed this because tizian just
destroyed this because he's like no the
look on the guy's face is why the [__]
are you taking a picture of me at the
urinal
also the thing that that thing that what
Republicans want is is trans people to
go in the wrong bathroom I can't I can't
explain to you how they don't realize
what here's what's gonna happen with uh
with bathroom bills and all this
anti-trans and it's just dehumanizing
people is all it is doing that's all
they're trying to do is dehumanize I'm
going to show you the clip from Michael
Knowles the daily wire and he even says
he wants to dehumanize them it's not in
so many words but that's what he's
saying but here's what's gonna happen
there is gonna be
dads taking their little daughters to
the bathroom and their daughter is going
to go in the bathroom and they're gonna
wait outside for their daughter because
that he can't go in that bathroom and
then there's gonna be a guy a man who
walks in that bathroom behind him and
the reason why is because it's the law
that that that woman who biologically is
a woman who was a woman at one time now
identifies as a man has to go in that
bathroom
and he's gonna be like what the [__] a
dude just walked in this bathroom that's
because that's what you wanted you
wanted that you want that and you're
gonna freak out when you're standing at
the urinal and some hot woman walks in
here you're touching your wiener it
might get a little semi and then the
woman walks to the urinal and starts
pissing next to you that's what you
wanted that's what you wanted you're not
understanding the [__] consequences
of your stupid ass logic you're not
understanding what it is or they want
the ability for someone to go into the
wrong bathroom right that they that they
deem right you can't go into this
bathroom and as soon as somebody goes in
that bathroom and say well we got to
pull down those pants we got to lift up
that skirt yeah who's gonna well that's
a good point Who's Gonna check their gym
and then someone's gonna be like well
you know what I got one of those fake
nursing degrees from Florida and I know
the difference
well they they really they haven't
really thought this through right and
thought the process through of the
reason why we don't actually have laws
that deem men's and women's bathrooms a
lot of local codes dictate that
um but it's not a a criminal law the
other thing too is we have laws against
I don't know molestation sexual
harassment rape all kinds of laws that
would prevent a person from from
accosting someone in a [__] bathroom
so this idea that we have to have this
is only out of their pure hatred but I
tell you what they want and Michael
Knowles is going to tell you in the One
Clip but I'm going to show you this bill
um Governor Bill Lee [__] first
um is that they want to dehumanize them
to where they aren't part of our society
they do not want them as part of our
society they want to get rid of them
they don't want to have them they want a
genocide they want rid of them they
don't want to have to deal with the
thought that is a them problem it's a
you problem if you're concentrating on
someone else's genitalia it's a [__]
you problem not the person who's got the
genitalia's problem so let me show you
this um
Tennessee holler has this of course says
watch the quote is have you guys seen
Governor Bill Lee and drag at a school
with minors should this have been a
felony because under their bill this
would likely be a felony
um and what happens is they showed Bill
Lee's 1977 yearbook photo
um two Republican Representatives that
are supporting this bill clearly the
only thing they should be be illegal uh
when gay people do it and that is that
is what that is what this bill is but
watch this tape here this is uh some
Republican Representatives who are in
support of this [__] dehumanizing
bill to dehumanize Americans and people
in Tennessee including residents of
Tennessee and citizens of Tennessee
watch as they tried to show this picture
this is Bill Lee in that dress he's in
drag
in a school year book watch as they show
one of the most significant things but
watch this
it's a good question huh should this be
a criminal offense right here what if I
show this to the Boy Scouts
good old days good old days
is that the illegal this should be okay
but that should be illegal remember you
said drag makes you sick this is
Governor William Drive
he's not gay
seriously why is he good drag queen
Story Hour you're good with that I'm
doing sexual explicit what will make
something sexually expensive they're
doing sexual things and I mean it's in
the Miller test obscenity what's
obscenity is already illegal man why so
if they're not doing anything obscene
then they're okay so what does this law
do
which one the one that you pass in here
the other law that you voted for it says
if they do anything obscene while
they're in the performance that they
can't do that do you say that's already
illegal yeah
I don't think that's what you voted for
but
this has been a felony
[Music]
stop
I want to report a crime this was on a
high school campus could this be a
felony Tim Governor Lee on a high school
campus in drag or is it only a felony
when they're gay
everybody you should go follow Tennessee
holler on every single [__] platform
that you can I will support their media
excuse me support their media every way
you can this this is a video on how to
handle these [__] scumbags in person
you challenge them you make them say out
loud what the [__] they're what the [__]
they're doing and and he knows what
they're doing they're criminalizing and
dehumanizing people and that's exactly
what this intent of this bill is there's
no other intent for it has nothing to do
with who's dressing what it is to
demonize the lgbtq community and drive
them out of Tennessee because it's a you
problem for Republicans it's a you
problem for conservatives and it's a you
problem for Christianity so please do me
a favor and support Independent Media
and in Tennessee The Independent Media
to support is a Tennessee holler sorry I
didn't mean to get too crazy there we go
yeah it's because yeah and they do this
because they're [__] ass [__] that's
why the same thing I tell you about
Rhonda Sands is making up fictional
[__] fights trans people make up such
an infinite infinite infinitesimally
small percentage of our society that
they can go [__] pick on these people
and try to dehumanize them and it costs
them almost nothing because they're
[__] ass [__] I mean they they
always want to find the easy guy to
[__] go out and Bully it's just who
they are and you look at them trying to
tie themselves up into freaking pretzels
trying to justify this [__] well it's
obscenity well there was no obscenity at
that drag queen Story Hour
so what's the [__] point you know I
mean give me a break I mean this is such
[__] well you missed the obscenity
part no I didn't and he's absolutely
right there's already obscenity laws on
the books you can't be obscene with a
child that's not what they were doing
they were reading them books that's all
you know Zenith says Tennessee holler
yes it's it is a independent news
organization it's just a few people uh
running it over there just go Google the
Tennessee holler or just go to social
media platforms and search it uh Gabe
did you you had comments you wanted to
have them oh I was saying I uh you know
I don't know through Tennessee holler or
someone else uh find the people that
were in that photo right those girls
those teenage girls who are obviously
not teenage now because that was back
then
uh and even though the lawsuit or the
case would get thrown out immediately I
would just say for publicity's sake to
file a lawsuit against
the governor
uh
uh Governor Lee to to say that he had
violated this world law right of course
again it would get tossed out but the
idea that you would get this on the
record not just the photo but now you
would get him actually attached to the
event and say well in his past we're now
suing him or coming against him because
he actually broke the law or broke you
know
this this uh
this act and to reveal
how dumb it is right and to mock them
and say well if you guys think legally
that there's no standing
for a case like this then there's no
there's no reason to have bills like
this actually be passed or proposed
right
um well there is a video that Tennessee
holler has and you'll have to go find it
because I gotta work we're short on time
here and I have to show you this Michael
Knowles
um video it is [__] disgusting and
bio and it but it it is driving what all
those Representatives because they don't
believe that [__] [__] they
really don't believe that oh Governor
Lee was okay did it in 1977 he's a good
guy so he did it it's it's more of the
not for not for me but for the these
regulations are not for me I get to do
what the [__] I want I'm a white man I'm
a white man he's a white man he just do
he's just he's he's straight white man
cisgender to just do whatever he wants
but anyone who's outside of that doesn't
get to do whatever they want and we get
to tell them what the [__] to do
um and that's more of this from Michael
Knowles and the daily wire you [__]
scumbags over there Dave wire you
[__] you [__] pieces of
Nazi [__] listen to this garbage that I
called to ban transgenderism entirely
I made the point that if you want if you
want women to have their own bathrooms
if you think women ought to be all right
I want to give you a little bit of
context here before we go too far
Michael Knowles has his own show on The
Daily wire but this is the [__] [__]
box that helps host Ted Cruz's show
whatever the [__] it's called I don't
even know what the [__] it's called
[__] it dumpster fire with Ted Cruz I
don't know but this [__]
hateful bigot ass [__] is the
one who's on Ted Cruz I think he's like
his his co-host or he's produced some
[__] I don't know but this [__]
here now the other thing I want to tell
you about this is he is he's saying he
wants to ban transgenderism remember we
were told last year that the number one
problem with our country is gas prices
Joe Biden inflation and here they are
they're wanting to get big government
all up in your [__] business or your
[__] genitalia or what you're gonna
do and what consent you're gonna give
and I told you all year last year that's
what these [__] were gonna push
if they won and that is what they're
trying to do now listen to what he says
oh man I I would hate to be within
spitting distance of this [__]
but um listen to what he says how he
wants to dehumanize transgender people
because that's what he's doing here he's
able to have their own locker rooms and
not have to look at
gigantic gross men while little girls
are getting changed if you want any of
those things
you have to ban transgenderism entirely
it's not enough to say well you have to
wait until you're 12 or whatever people
are saying now it has to be the whole
thing because if men have the right to
behave as women and identify as women
for the purposes of public life
then women can't have their own spaces
and I'm so glad he's for women's rights
oh my God let me tell you something
about how I'm sure that women are just
terrified if another woman comes into a
bathroom minds her own [__] business
and uses the stall next to him hopefully
Michael Knowles won't be in there
looking over the [__] stall to see
what goddamn genitalia they have and
what the [__] is a giant man gonna be
doing in a locker room for little kids
Michael the [__] that they just make us
I'm apparently he's watched Matt Walsh
do it probably he's watched every one of
these other [__] talk about it
and someone needs to check Michael
Knowles's lab tap top stat sorry go back
just just go back to the beginning
because what he says I feel like he's
gonna say something else he says
gigantic and then there's a pregnant
pause let's see if I can get the if you
want any of those things and not have to
look at able to have their own locker
rooms in the bathrooms if you think
women ought to be able to have their own
locker rooms and not have to look at
gigantic gross men while little girls
are getting changed he was gonna say
gigantic penis right they're obsessed
with it they're obsessed about this this
person's gigantic dick and he's like
that's all I got I got dick dick dick
all over my forehead in my mind I can't
get it out and the only way to think
about it is with little kids and that is
his weird I bet Michael Michael I'm
calling on you to come on the show and
expose your [__] search history on
the internet I want to see what porn
you're looking at buddy that's what I
want to know I want it it's weird [__]
oh it's it's it's nasty [__] illegal and
I'm not opposed to nasty porn my the
audience knows I love porn and I love
nasty porn but I bet Michael Knowles has
the secrets that he's hiding here let's
keep listening
and can't have their own spaces and we
as a society cannot have our own
standards and norms and we're not
allowed to live according to reality we
have to live according to the delusions
of these troubled people
and I think we the people have a right
to reality and I think women have a
right to their own spaces and so that
means you got to ban the thing entirely
and oh my goodness what these people say
they said that I was calling for the
extermination of transgender people what
is what is a total ban to make sure that
no one can be trans than an
extermination of trans what more is that
you uh if I said anything Gabe Sanchez
if I said you can't be openly Mexican
you cannot you can't do it you just
can't do it we're not going to allow it
it's it's a travesty that you would be
uh an open openly Mexican in this
country and we're going to ban you to be
uh identify as Mexican
what does that mean to you what would
that mean to you
I mean the idea well honestly what it
means to me is like removing my identity
removing what is me what I am what what
why like what what makes me me
is the fact that I am Mexican right and
what makes those people what they are is
because they feel comfortable to say you
know what I am trans and I am proud of
it and I feel comfortable this way and
how I am in my body
but I love that I love the fact that
Michael Knowles goes oh we gotta give
women their own space we got to make
sure they're protected yeah but also I'm
gonna take away all your other rights
that you would have to determine your
own choice of your space
where is he Michael moles is a white man
I done told you this in the last in the
last sorry you mean a white boy right
well and white boy this white boy gets
the has the privilege to tell other
people what rights they're gonna get and
what rights they're not gonna get don't
you understand how this works Texas Paul
we've been trying to tell Gabe this for
a long time and he clearly understand
that that white men white men that get
to dictate what rights you get and what
rights you know I'm with babe on this
one I I'm with Gabe on this one and I'm
just going to add a little positive spin
on this is that while this piece of [__]
is out here worrying about who's got a
dick in their drawers
Joe Biden and his administration is now
creating jobs and doing things for the
American people just keep that in mind
keep in mind what people are doing right
now you know what else you know what
else the administration is doing for
child for children save the children
this is this Michael Knowles he's part
of the save the children ground he's
making sure that they can't be exploited
by corporations for their labor that's
something crazy but let's listen to this
guy's absolute [__] delusion
I said I was calling for a genocide
against her I said what I must have
missed that part of my show when did I
did I say that
I don't one I don't know how you could
have a genocide of transgender people
because genocide refers to genes ah
Jesus Christ no listen this is the part
this is the part that I'm talking about
I know it's hard but this is where he
dehumanizes them watch how he
dehumanizes and listen to it it refers
to genetics it refers to biology and the
whole point of transgenderism is that it
has nothing to do with Biology
that's what the transgender activists
say they say forget [__] typical sex
oh I I know you're going to disagree but
listen to what he says yeah listen to
what he says here listen to what he says
my gender expression doesn't have to
have anything to do with my biological
sex okay well then there can be a
genocide that refers to genetics but
furthermore nobody's calling to
exterminate anybody because the other
problem with that
statement is that
transgender people is not a real
ontological category it's not a
legitimate category of being
it's not a legitimate category of being
so they're not human beings Texas ball
they're just not they're not human
beings
Michael Knowles a [__] bigot he's
[__] wrong biologically trans people
that that see themselves as as an
opposite sex have biologically different
brains that is that are dictated by
their [__] genetics
a a a a a a
male trans person that is was born in a
female's body has white matter and here
their hippocampus and everything in
their brain mirrors that of a man
that is a genetic distinction that they
have so [__] this guy for being a bigot
and [__] this guy for being wrong
well this is this is daily wires this is
their content production
um almost every single day right now is
to dehumanize American citizens and
dehumanize the lgbtq community that is
their goal that is their aim and
obviously uh when he's not I how Gabe
Sanchez how is it genocide when these
people aren't even human I mean come on
I mean that was a genocide when these
people aren't even human I mean genocide
if they're not human right I mean I'm
using that logic and the way that he
talks about it right he's got he's
disgusting pieces from the point at
which genocide comes up right he's the
people said I was if I was talking about
genocide I don't know when that happened
in my show the smile that he has and the
the kind of joy that he gets out of that
he's like I never talked about that yes
I did but if I if I did talk about it
right it's because this right it's the
whole thing like oh well you know
if it's O.J Simpson like look if I did
kill my wife I would have done it this
way and the way that he's talking about
this is very much like look I mean if it
were to be genocide it's based and then
he runs through the whole [__]
diatribe of like well it's not this
because of genetics in it and he's like
look I already plea I pre-planned the
reason as to justify
why I would be okay with genocide but
also I'm trying to argue here that these
people aren't actually uh to have Merit
like and also what he's saying is like
these people don't even get the label of
having genocide because genetically
they're they're not they're not these
humans they're not these you want to
know let me
I I history's a [__] I mean it is a
[__] most time we can learn from
history but these stupid [__]
fascists just don't know what history
they're spewing there was a time in our
world it was that in in Europe and it
was a country oh man what's that I think
it's Germany I think it's the country it
was in like the 1930s or 1940s
um there was a group
a political group that took over the
government there
um I forget the head of that group I
think his name was uh hike heikler or
hickler or something like that
um something close that they love this
guy they [__] love that guy they
[__] love them they raised him they
almost worshiped him and you know what
you know what they did to an entire
group of people they dehumanized them to
commit genocide and that's how they
started the whole process was to make
sure to dehumanize them so they could
commit genocide against them what was
that called a smaller cost or Holocaust
nothing like that I can't remember
exactly what it's called look folks this
is exactly what they're trying to do
here and they're trying to gather up
enough support to get Donald Trump to be
the president so he can start doing
their bidding on this on on this
terrible [__] sludge of fascism this
is what they want and they want us to
fight this battle in this Arena and I
know we can have a lot of arguments and
and Texas Paul brings up some good
arguments about the science but if word
not basing our arguments based on simple
humanity and decency and [__] Liberty
we are going to lose these fights in
these states because what daily wire is
doing is pushing this [__] in these
states because Matt Walsh went to
[__] Tennessee testify for that
stupid [__] bill that [__] scumbag
and that is the reason why they keep
pushing this because if one state does
it they'll Florida is going to out
Tennessee Tennessee and then Texas will
out out Florida and then Missouri is
going to have Texas Texas and it's going
to go on and on and on until they have
their little National divorce that
Marjorie Taylor green was talking about
because what they want is they want
refuge for [__] bigots that's what
they want they want a refuge for [__]
bigots and we can't give it to them so
please support Independent Media go
ahead text ball that that's the secret
sauce right there is what you're talking
about they want refuge for bigots
because these people know the the [__]
that they're thinking is wrong and they
feel repressed because they have been
they've been [__] stuffed in the
closet forever because the [__] they say
and think is [__] wrong and the
Secret Sauce the [__] drug the
Christopher rufos the the you know it's
[__] Knowles they all know what it is
you take these bigots and racists and
you tell them it's okay man it's okay
your thoughts are valid and just as
valid as everybody else they will
[__] follow you forever
forever because you let them be as
shitty as they want to be and it feels
great to them
that that's that's what this is bottom
line what you're talking about the
dehumanization of these people is is to
take people that are so [__] shitty
that they will do anything to anybody
and tell them hey you're all right
you're okay you're acceptable we we we
like you man
Texas Paul give us uh we're gonna have
to wrap here we're over time of course
we aren't because there's so much [__]
to get to
um but tell us give us Shameless plug
you get your show on your YouTube
channel I got the link down below you
can go visit realtexaspaul.com and give
us a plug Bingo every Sunday nine
o'clock nine a.m I do a weekly uh
Roundup of all the news that's going on
and you're gonna like I said
www.realtexaspaul.com we'll give you a
click right click right to it awesome
awesome uh Gabe Sanchez do you have a
what was that that's coming out soon I I
do I'm uh I'll be filming uh another
what was that uh today it's gonna be
about uh January 6 footage going into
Tucker Carlson Republican leadership
questioning his uh his decision and then
ultimately
um Mike Lindell suing or saying he plans
to sue Kevin McCarthy over releasing the
footage only to Fox News we couldn't
even get to that today because there's
so much so go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out all the extras over
there what was that and why you're on
patreon.com visit mypage too the Tony
Michaels thank you very much
122 uh members over on my patreon that's
incredible thank you very much to
everyone who's has joined over there
um I didn't realize how fast I get 200
and my goal now is 150 so if you help me
out on that too but check out Gabe
Sanchez's page check out my page also
and then go check out the links down
below for Texas fall
realtexaspaul.com but while you're here
on the YouTube channel don't forget to
hit subscribe and it's [__] free it's
free then cost you goddamn thing to
subscribe the YouTube channel or follow
me on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod it
doesn't cost anything to download free
99 as Gabe Sanchez said yesterday it's
free 99 five finger discount on the Tony
Michaels podcast this afternoon on Apple
Spotify Google you can steal it for free
also follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and here's another cool thing
that you can do for free that doesn't
cost you a single nickel if you're an
Amazon Prime member you can go log into
twitch with your Amazon Prime account
and you get one free subscription one
and you can give it to us and we
actually get money for that it's not
it's like a couple bucks but every
single month but hey it all adds up in
the end it all adds up and it's free for
you to do so those are some free ways
you can support the show we really
appreciate having you here
until tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon